of all the Axis powers or their allies
Thailand is one of the least disgusted
it's a country which prior to the war
had little contact with the rest of the
axis and were surrounded by Allied
colonies which given the risks raises
the question why did Thailand help the
axis so Thailand was famously a nation
that avoided colonization by European
powers and whilst it was never a part of
anybody's Empire there were still
territorial losses these came at the
hands of two Powers the British who in
the late 19th and early 20th centuries
took these lands and the French who
during the same period robbed Thailand
of all of this it won't surprise you to
know that as a result the Tai held quite
a grudge against the British and the
French although mostly the French in the
1930s Thailand found itself ruled by a
military dictatorship headed by PL fibon
zram who wanted to get these lands back
the only way that the new government
figured it could do that was by growing
the economy modernizing the armed forces
and waiting for a moment of weakness and
this moment came in 1940 when Britain
was on the back foot and France was in a
spot of surrender the ties realized that
paris's hold over Indochina wasn't that
strong anymore and so now was the time
the Bangkok Government tried to
negotiate with vishy France for the
return of these territories and the
French said no as such it was time to
try and make friends and the best
candidate was Japan the Japanese
government was eyeing up French Indo
China and if Japan took all of it then
Thailand would struggle to get anything
back at all fortunately the Japanese had
been sending delegates to Bangkok to
entice the Thai to join them in a future
war against the British because Japan
needed to cross Thailand to get to India
and Singapore and as such the Thai
government told the Japanese that they
would give the military access to their
lands in return for this territory the
Japanese said yes and so sent weapons to
Thailand who began to prepare for an
invasion which they telegraphed to the
world Japan Germany and Italy were all
for it whereas Britain made it clear
that they weren't going to defend
France's Asian territories it just
wanted assurances that Thailand wasn't
going to attack India or Malaya the
Americans were opposed but they weren't
involved in the war so nobody cared what
they thought Thai forces invaded French
Indochina in late 1940 and whilst the
did well at first the Japanese were
concerned that the French could
eventually hold them off and as such
they intervened and negotiated it was
decided that French Indochina soon to
become Japanese Indochina would seed
this territory to Thailand in return for
them aiding the Japanese now this wasn't
Thailand formerly joining the axis
Berlin and Rome didn't care about
Bangkok but it was useful to Tokyo which
was enough however when the time came to
help FIB SRAM refused he declared
neutrality and hoped that the Japanese
would just go around they did not
knowing that he was going to lose he
quickly made an agreement with the
Japanese and alongside them declared war
on the United States and the United
Kingdom Now Thailand didn't enjoy its
position as an ally of Japan and when
Tokyo's Fortune started to change
Thailand's rulers looked for a way out
to keep them sweet the Japanese seeded
these territories but it still wasn't
enough fibms Crown was removed from
office in 1944 and the new government
secretly tried to get the Allies on
board the British reluctantly agreed so
long as the territory that Thailand had
taken from it was returned however the
British didn't care if the French got
theirs back or not and with that
Thailand role in World War II was over
and in 1948 fibon SRAM would be back in
charge because he didn't like Communists
and that was good enough in the Cold War
I hope you enjoyed this episode with a
special thanks to my patrons James Bizet
Kelly Money Maker Sky Chappelle kitka
Anthony Becket rod D Martin Udan Wang
Marcus arner Yan hockey Alex Schwin AF
Firefly Captain side dog Spencer
Lightfoot Gustav Swan the mcer shuen in
Marvin CAU Winston kwood spinning three
plates Andy McGee kimun Yun calling Dr
Howard Dr Fine Dr Howard Todd short
copper tone Maggie patkowski words about
books podcast Jim Stromberg Miss iset
and Charles I
first